[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on
sunday tens of thousands died
who didn't need to that's the claim made
this week by
dominic cummings who we can be pretty
sure didn't get an invitation to
celebrate his former boss's wedding
yesterday
in seven hours of testimony to mps he
painted a picture of dithering and
incompetence
among the johnson administration senior
ministers civil servants
and advisers and perhaps most damningly
he says that the problems which led the
government to let people down
are still in place today in the next
hour we'll ask what needs to change
to do better next time because there
will be
a next time
in a moment we'll be speaking to the
vaccines minister nadim zahawi
the shadow leader of the house fam
debonair tells us what labour would have
done
differently we'll be asking one of
britain's leading public health experts
professor linda bold what she made of
dominic cummings testimony earlier in
the week
and is he right that so many senior
officials are completely
out of their debt lord kurzlake is a
cross-bench peer
and former head of the civil service
we'll also take a look under the bonnet
of the government with one who's been
there and done that former downing
street head of communications
aleister campbell and finally around one
in three of all coveted deaths were in
care homes we'll be speaking to the
chair of the independent care group
mike padgeam but first the vaccines
minister
nadim zahawi good morning minister
um did you get an invitation to the
wedding yesterday
no but i want to congratulate the prime
minister
and uh carrie simmons uh on tying the
knot
uh and it's a a great uh
feeling uh as uh you come together and
of course
i think it's it's a wonderful thing for
both of them uh that they
uh have uh uh
really sort of made their their their
marriage vows to one another
um the fact that this came out of the
blue is this a kind a hint
to all couples who are waiting
uh and delaying their marriage hoping
that after june the 21st
they'll be able to invite more than 30
people was the prime minister's
uh and carrie simmons decision to go
yesterday a hint that there's no point
june the 21st
is not going to be what we hope it was
going to be
no i wouldn't extrapolate anything from
that uh
trevor on the 14th of june we will set
out
very clearly uh the data that we are
continuing to gather
from of step three which was on the
17th of may and then we'll share that
with the nation
as the prime minister has done in each
and every step from
step one two and three and then of
course step four
uh we continue to vaccinate at scale we
are
almost at 39 million people now with at
least one dose
and almost 25 million people with two
doses so uh
i think the important thing is to keep
going vaccinating at scale but also
share the data on the uh
14th of june okay as we have done in the
past to give people
the the ability then to to plan ahead
okay what we'll um
interrogate just how consistent the
government has been
with that data not dates promise
in a moment but um i just want to put
you that ask you
this morning about a story that's in the
sunday times
saying that it intelligence sources
have um suggested that it's feasible
that's their word that the worldwide
pandemic
came from a chinese lab in wuhan
um makes sense to you and why is it
taking so
long to get to the point where we just
know it's feasible
well i think it's really important that
the who
is allowed to conduct its investigation
unencumbered
into the origins of this pandemic
and that we should leave no stone
unturned to understand
why not only because of obviously the
current
uh pandemic that is uh has swept the
world but also
for future uh uh future proofing
uh the world's capability to deal with
pandemics and it was also really good to
see
the prime minister announced the sort of
global radar
uh which we are leading the way we we
account for just under 50
of all genome sequencing of this virus
and the setting up of a global radar
to be able to track uh virus mutations
virus variants is going to be incredibly
important but the who has to be able to
conduct
its investigation unencumbered you you
you have to depend on who data and
guidance for
a lot of the things that you do in your
job do you feel comfortable depending on
an agency that's saying now it's
feasible that this came
out of a lab in wuhan but in january was
saying that a leak
was extremely unlikely does that seem
like an agency that you can trust
well i think the who at every step of
the way has tried to share
as much data with the world as it is
able to verify this is a very difficult
situation as we've seen
around the world not just um in the who
but of course
in our own country with our own evidence
gathering
and of course advice and in other
countries every country whether it's
singapore or
uh australia or new zealand or elsewhere
we've all had to
you know collect evidence and then act
upon it and i think it's only right
that the who is allowed to conduct its
investigation
unencumbered uh to be able for all of us
to understand and to deal with
this and future pandemics i i asked this
minister because
at the heart of um this week's con
discussions
have been the question whether we can
trust our authorities and
i i want to come to the uh issue of
um what dominic cummings has been saying
to us this week he took aim at the civil
service
at ministers indeed at himself but his
greatest accusation
was that tens of thousands of people who
didn't need to die
perished because of your government's
failures
and because you didn't level with the
people he said i think that the idea
that any kind of serious inquiry and
lessons learned
doesn't start until next year is
completely terrible
the families of all tens of thousands of
people who died
didn't need to die there is absolutely
uh no excuse for delaying the inquiry
because a lot of the reasons for why
that happened
are still in place now what he's really
saying is the most damning
aspect of his allegation is that the
failures
of the government that we can't trust
government and that the failures and
mistakes
that uh led us to this situation are
still
there how can we trust you
well i would say a couple of things on
this one is that
we will have a proper statutory inquiry
where people will come and give evidence
under oath so we've heard you know
parts of that the story of course every
life lost is
a grandfather grandmother father uncle
aunt i lost my
uncle to this uh terrible virus
because we couldn't get him vaccinated
in time although he was eligible
for it so i know the pain of losing
loved ones to this virus we've also
saved many lives the
public health england's data the last
series of data suggests that
almost 40 000 people have been spared
going into hospital and serious illness
because of the vaccination program
over 13 000 um have
not lost their life are alive today
because of the vaccination program so i
think
the right thing to do is to wait for
that inquiry in spring of 2022. let me
tell you why i think it's the right
thing
to do trevor just one one tiny thing if
you listen to
professor jonathan van tam who's working
all hours
19 hours a day seven days a week and he
literally
was pleading with the nation to say
please not now because we need to carry
on
we remain in the middle of a very
serious situation
with the coronavirus pandemic and of
course the rest of the world remains in
that situation as well
so it has to be the right thing to do is
to have
an inquiry when we can learn the lessons
and we will absolutely do that
and of course sorry we hear this point
minister we hear this point
however ministers come on programs like
this all the time
and i've heard matt hancock say this
maybe a dozen times we are learning all
the time
we are learning new things as we're
going along and we know things
that we didn't know last year now
cummings had some choice words
about ministers and their shortcomings
and he said in particular about matt
hancock
that he should have been fired at least
15 times
for putting it let's put it mildly
misleading the public
by claiming he had been putting a shield
around care homes last year
cummings said we were told categorically
in march that people would be tested
before they went back to care homes we
only subsequently found out
that had not happened now all the
government rhetoric was
we've put a shield around care homes and
blah blah blah coming said
it was complete nonsense quite the
opposite of putting a shield around them
we sent people back
to uh to care homes with coving now the
point here
is not whether the vaccination
uh program has worked whether you've
tried your best
but whether when you speak to the public
you have been clear you have been direct
you have told us the truth and the whole
truth
you have leveled with us cummings is
saying
that the one thing that you can control
which is what you say to the public
you haven't actually done straight
well i don't recognize that
characterization because
i've been working for the past seven
months with
matt hancock and i can tell you that
every day
he comes into the office and he focuses
on using every resource available to us
to be able to save lives not least with
this
vaccine rollout that i've been
responsible for reporting
into him and into the prime minister i
think it's really important to remember
and to put a bit of context around this
trevor
you know in the eye the storm of a
pandemic
early last year we only had the
capability to conduct about 2 000 tests
a day you know our diagnostics
capability in the uk
was almost non-existent today
last week last seven days we conducted
over six million tests so to say that
you know hindsight is a wonderful thing
but to say that you know
for some reason we haven't been leveling
with people i think is
wrong and is mistaken at every stage
matt hancock used every resource
available to him to do his
best possible job for the people that he
needed to protect
this is not hindsight let's deal with a
question i actually asked you nobody's
contesting
whether ministers worked hard whether
you tried to do your best
the question was whether you told us
the truth that you knew it now the
last summer a consultant geriatrician
at told the british medical journal
journaled this
before any instruction from nhs england
emergency legislation or government cash
injections
acute hospitals around the country were
busy implementing
escalation plans to prevent hospitals
from being swamped
many of us were in good faith and for
understandable reasons
in that early pandemic context sending
people to care homes
with or without covet 19 testings
look this is a senior consultant in a
big london hospital
all he's saying is that government had a
difficult choice to make
and you decided the more important thing
to do is to protect hospitals
even if that meant some risk to care
homes why can't you just say
you had a hard choice to make and you
made a brave
call why can't you just say that
well i i think what i was trying to say
to you is
exactly um the situation that
as we found ourselves in early last year
when we entered this pandemic we could
only conduct about 2 000 tests
a day and you had to make sure that you
test the front line as well as those
who are being discharged into care homes
and on the 15th of april when
that decision was made and shared with
the country and
with the system that people will be
tested
the nhs then operationalized that and we
grew
testing capacity and that target of a
hundred thousand i think was
equally important because actually
setting targets in government is a good
thing as i have discovered that there
was and then
and then we continue to expand it trevor
so so i don't
think minister yeah you must have known
sorry there was
some risk why can't you just say
we knew that but we had a big decision
to make
and we decided making sure that the nhs
was not
overwhelmed was the priority
but but both were the priorities trevor
that's the whole thing what i'm trying
to explain to you is
both things were the priority but we
know hindsight is a wonderful thing you
work with the resources you have you do
your best
with whatever resource you have
available to you at the time
as well as then investing in growing it
so if you start
a pandemic with the ability to only
conduct 2 000
tests a day you quite rightly say to
yourself how am i going to get to a
place
where i can do over six million tests in
seven days which is what we've just
delivered this past seven days
that is the whole point is you grow we
we've begun this pandemic only
able to manufacture two percent of our
ppe we now manufacture
about 70 percent of our ppe diagnostics
was similar 2000 and now as i say the
capability to do oh probably over a
million a day
of tests so i don't i don't see these
things are as
as being a trade-off you have to do both
things
but you do them with the resources that
are available to you at the time
it really wasn't what anybody said at
the time and it sounds a little bit like
boris johnson cakism that
you want it both ways but let's just
deal with some of your own
responsibilities right
now minister um you personally see
overseen the great success of this
administration
50 million vaccine vaccination doses
third of population you've talked
about it earlier in this conversation
we've got a lot of stocks we've got
machinery
why aren't you keeping up the pace and
giving jobs to children as recommended
by the european medical agency
well because first of all our own
regulator has not yet
approved giving vaccines to children
you have to make sure the vaccines are
incredibly safe before
you give them to children we've seen the
pfizer
biontic vaccine being approved by the uh
us
regulator and the canadian regulator for
12 to 15 year olds
um the mhra our own independent
regulator
and of course the joint committee on
vaccination in the united states we'll
have to look
very carefully at this because of course
you're not vaccinating children
um some obviously get infected and get
long covered but on the whole you're
vaccinated to protect their families and
their communities
and the country so vaccines as chris
whittier say
have to be incredibly safe before you
administer the children but we will be
ready
the infrastructure we've built uh allows
us the the ability to deploy vaccines
for
12 to 15 year olds as well as of course
planning for the boost
in the autumn and the flu vaccination
campaign
so the infrastructure is there but of
course the clinicians
have to make that final decision there
is um there are reports today that you
want to make potentially vaccination
compulsory
for nhs staff to make sure that you
crack down on spread of the virus in
hospitals
for some people that makes sense is that
what's going to happen
so we've recently consulted on the
social care front line staff in terms
of duty of care to those
who are most vulnerable you and i've
been talking about the residents
of care homes who were by the way put at
the top of the list
of the vaccination program and that duty
of care
we've been consulting on in terms of
condition of deployment into social care
i think it's only right that we look at
the health care system as well we've
been talk you and i've been talking
about infections
um out of hospital it's
absolutely the right thing it would be
incumbent on any responsible government
to have the debate to have the to do the
thinking
as to how we go about protecting the
most vulnerable by making make sure that
those who look after them
are vaccinated there is precedent for
this obviously
surgeons get vaccinated for hepatitis b
so it's something that we are absolutely
thinking about so
it's possible let me just ask you one
last question minister thank you for
your
time um you've had to depend
on the what people call this the white
hole machine
civil service public health england and
so on one of the issues that emerged out
of cummings is testimony
is his pretty dusty opinion
of the uh level of delivery and the
capability
of uh the civil service in a crisis
what do you say to cummings and indeed
other people who've been saying this
week
that with the best will in the world a
lot of clever people in our civil
service
it literally is not up to snuff not
modern enough
not capable and that actually we need to
take some urgent action
to get that machine into the 21st
century
i would respectfully disagree
and i tell you for why and i've been
doing this job now for
seven months and i you know wished that
dominic cummings
was because he wasn't involved in the
vaccination program
but i wish he was there because he would
see the capability of the civil service
whether it be maddie mcternan who's my
senior
responsible officer on vaccine supply
ruth todd who works with her steve glass
or
emily lawson the brilliant senior
responsible officer
at the nhs doing the deployment he would
have seen the civil service
at its best coming together with our
armed forces
with of course the nhs family doctors
nurses
uh the gps the pharmacists all coming
together
with the private sector of course and
local government local government has
been an incredibly integral part of this
he would have seen a machinery of
government coming together with
extraordinary talent in the civil
service
delivering this program and i if if he'd
been there
i think he would have maybe possibly had
a different point of view
in front of the committee you said over
the last seven months the civil service
had its best
uh delivers but the problem is it's
probably not all
always at its best let me quote you what
uh mr cummings had to say on all of this
we all should be asking and you guys in
the political parties need to ask
yourselves
um what is it about your parties that
give choices like johnson and corbyn
and we have to ask what is it about
whitehall
that promotes so many people who are
completely
out of their depth do you have no
uh sympathy with that view
well all i can say to you and we all
fall back on the experiences that we
have
the experience of being the vaccine
deployment minister
i don't recognize that point of view
there are extraordinary talent people
in the civil service doing an incredible
job and i can tell you because i came
out of the private sector
into politics as you know trevor you and
i go back a long way
i would hire all of them in a heartbeat
they are amazing people
doing amazing work working all hours and
delivering
operationally competent people as i say
if dominic cummings had been
you know involved in the vaccination
program i suspect he may have changed
his mind
on that view that he gave the committee
minister thank you very much for your
time this morning
thank you now as many as three quarters
of all new coronavirus infections across
the uk involved the
so-called indian variant and the health
secretary matt hancock says that the
number of new cases is rising again
throughout the country
that rising rate of infection is casting
doubt on whether the government really
can
lift remaining restrictions on june the
21st
public health expert professor linda
bold joins us
from edinburgh professor bold you heard
what the minister has to say um does
that sound
like we are heading to end of lockdown
on june 21st to you
i think it's very ambitious trevor
looking at the national picture
the average seven day average for cases
at the moment is well over three
thousand if you look back just to the
first week of may we were around two
thousand
and in some parts of the country
including parts here in scotland
we've seen a big increase and i know
that's not translating yet
to large numbers of people in hospital
but there are more people in hospital
particularly those in midlife who may
only have had one dose of the vaccine
so looking ahead the 21st of june is
very soon
and i think to avoid more preventable
deaths that you've just been discussing
with the minister
we really need to be cautious at the
current time
so you actually if you i know that
you're not in the policy territory but
if you had your way
you would actually have to be positively
uh
convinced that opening on june the 21st
is safe before you follow
the roadmap as it currently is which is
to lift all restrictions after that date
that's correct and i think even from
policy colleagues including in the
developed nations we've been hearing
very cautionary
messages and that we can't commit to
towards the end of june that the
summer solstice date i really think that
it's too early
to be charging ahead i would like to see
several more weeks data and the kind of
evidence i want to see
and all my colleagues is that these uh
chains of transmission these
links between the fact that we always
knew we'd have slightly more cases when
we opened up
but it's moving through the system to
then people becoming unwell we don't
want anyone to become
severely unwell with this virus and we
really got just over four in ten
of the population who've got good
protection from both doses
other countries final point on this that
have opened up fully like
israel have many more in their
population that have got full protection
from the vaccines and we're just not
there yet
but um professor bald you're you're
distinguished expert in behavioral
science
amongst other things
changing the signals which at the moment
say we're heading towards
opening do you think we're not israel do
you think that
britain would respond well to that or
are we now at risk of creating
a situation where a population has been
relatively compliant
seeing its summer holidays slipping away
uh
underneath lockdown might start to
revolt
well there's two points there the first
one is yes the the public are totally
fed up
everybody just wants things to go back
to normal or most things to go back to
normal
i think we recognize that and there is
frustration
but the government said particularly the
uk government said data not dates
and so i think they really do need to
follow the data and as i say at the
moment the situation is
is not entirely moving in the right
direction
on compliance we heard from dominic
cummings uh criticism
of behavioral scientists including on
spy b at the beginning of the pandemic
saying there would be behavioral
fatigue that didn't come from my
colleagues on spy b
and actually the british public the
levels of adherence and compliance have
been
truly astonishing and when you look at
the latest data some of the surveys that
have been done
there's a significant portion of the
population who are still very very
concerned
recognize that we shouldn't be rushing
ahead and so i don't think we're going
to see writing on the streets despite
the fact that we have had demonstrations
around vaccines etc
that's a small proportion what most
people in this country want
is not not more people to die to be able
to move ahead
and with more confidence and to know
that we're not going to have to take
backward steps and go back into local
or national restrictions nobody wants
that
so forgive me i i missed a second what
you were saying but
i might to understand that you actually
think that what mr cummings now
says he said at the time which was
harder faster
lockdown quicker was correct i think so
i mean i do have sympathy for some of
the decisions taken very early on in the
pandemic when we didn't know about
airborne transmission
and we didn't know so much about
asymptomatic transmission etc and a
number of countries in europe didn't act
quickly enough
and i think you know cummings evidence i
mean it was really shocking listening to
that and it will all be poured over
and i don't think we should you know be
necessarily making judgments now about
what he said that was correct and wasn't
correct but i think a lot of things he
said about decisions that were taken
that could have prevented such a big
second wave
and things we should have learned around
travel around ventilation
around moving cautiously protecting
particular groups
you know we're still not necessarily
being that cautious and using that
evidence so i think some of what he said
we really do need to learn from not in a
future public inquiry next year but
learn from now
well of course that's important now at
the heart of much of what we're doing
now is the relationship between
politics and science and i just want to
ask you because i'm interested in this
uh
as a scientist the government's been
saying from the start of this that
it has been and will be guided by the
science
listening to dominic cummings and
watching from your own experience and
your own participation
do you think that's actually what
happened not entirely no i mean
first of all there's no single science
scientists always disagree
and then the consensus needs to be
reached but it's very clear
you know we were delayed in getting the
sage paper so we can now all pour over
them
and it's clear at several points in the
pandemic the government didn't follow
the advice of sage
including the behavioral science advice
that's very clear but looking back to
the autumn recommendations around taking
early action in september those were not
taken so i don't think the government
has always followed the signs i think
it's completely incorrect to say
that's the case in some aspects they
have in some aspects they haven't and
the final point i would make there is
that one of the things
trevor to me that's most regrettable
about the last 14 months
is that governments have often blamed
the public uh
for things that have gone wrong the
public's behavior and just going back to
the data i was referring to
you know the public have suffered
they've tried their absolute best
and i think you know government needs to
take responsibility for
for what's occurred professor ball thank
you so much you'll know that we'll
return to this
many many times now the
labor leader kia starmer has this
morning warned that plans to lift nearly
all
lockdown restrictions on june 21st are
at risk because of what he calls
serial incompetence inside boris
johnson's government
would labor do any better
i'm joined now by the shadow leader of
the house of commons thangham
debonair miss debonair you listened to
the minister for vaccines do you believe
that the government was straight with us
well i think what we've seen
unfortunately is all throughout this
crisis a government that's been too slow
to take decisions at crucial points
everybody understood last march that it
was an unexpected
pandemic that there were difficult
decisions to have
it was too slow to heed the advice of
their own experts the leader of the
opposition
we needed a circuit breaker in the
autumn that advice was not taken
the advice again about christmas was not
taken those were difficult decisions but
that's the nature of leadership and the
prime minister
failed to show leadership when it
mattered and i'm afraid to say thousands
of people have suffered because of that
okay thank for forgive me there was a
small dropout in
in your signal there but i i think we'll
keep going on this um
let me start with the question i put to
back to the minister
do you do you think that the
compulsory vaccination of nhs staff
might be a wise move and would labour
support that even though it might mean
that people intentionally have to choose
whether they stay in their jobs or
they maintain a principled opposition
to vaccination
well given that we've got a recruitment
crisis in parts of the nhs i think it's
far more important we try and work with
staff rather than against them
threatening stuff i don't think is a
good idea i think it's where we've
done well in the vaccination program is
where public health england and nhs
been able to work with people on their
doubts and questions and give them
accurate information
that's seen the rates of vaccination go
up i would like to see the government
work with the nhs and social care staff
well that's fine to say let's work with
staff but there are some staff who
basically say i'm not having it because
i do not believe in it
and i won't take this vaccination uh
it's not possible to work with somebody
who has
a very sincere belief that they
shouldn't take this thing so
let me ask you again where will you
stand when we get if we get to that
point
well when i say work with i mean try and
find out why people have got reluctances
help them to get accurate information
all along the way of this vaccination
program which is a fantastic vaccine
program and all thanks to the
scientists and nhs staff have been
responsible for it more and more people
who were initially reluctant
have gradually decided to take the
vaccine because they can see it's the
right thing to do
now i think that that's a better way of
working with people than threatening
them
i think it's important that we listen to
what people's fears are but also think
about how we might organize
so that people can get that accurate
information and choose to take the
vaccine in a timely manner because it is
the best thing we can do to protect
ourselves and each other
your leader this morning's writing in
the newspapers about how labour would do
things better
let's just talk about a couple of
aspects of that first of all the
uh government machine everybody agrees
that
the government did one thing right which
is a vaccination program
but actually in order to get that right
they brought in an outsider
and a team from outside the vaccine task
force
which didn't operate according to the
conventional whitehall rules
now at the time labour said this was
awful tories cronies uh you
criticized kate bingham because she led
that task force
for spending too much money on public
relations
do you want to apologize to her now
oh well it seems that that question will
not be answered
by tangent debonair because she has
dropped off the signal okay
well we might say come back but in a
moment what we're going to try and do is
look under the bonnet of the government
with the former head of the civil
service to see what kind of shape
the machine's in but first let's remind
ourselves what dominic cummings
actually had to say on wednesday the
truth is that senior minister is senior
officials
senior advisers like me fell
disastrously short
of the standards that the public has a
right to expect of its government in a
crisis like this
when the public needed us most the
government failed
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die
the government rhetoric was we put a
shield around care homes and blah blah
it was complete nonsense quite the
opposite of putting a shield around them
we sent people with covert back to the
care homes
the secretary of state for health should
have been fired
for at least 15 20 things including
lying to everybody
in multiple occasions in meeting after
meeting in the
in the cabinet room and publicly the
view of various officials inside number
10 was
um if we have the prime minister chair
in cobra meetings and he just tells
everyone
it's swine flu don't worry about it i'm
going to get chris whitney to inject me
live on tv with coronavirus so everyone
realizes
it's nothing to be frightened of that
would be
that would not help actually serious
planning you guys in the political
parties need to ask yourselves
what is it about your parties that give
choices like
johnson versus corbett and we have to
ask what is it about whitehall
to promote so many senior people who are
completely out of their depth
there is no plan we're in huge trouble
i've come through here to the telemachu
morris said i've come through here to
the prime minister's office to tell you
all quote i think we are absolutely
lord curse lake bob kurzlek was head of
the civil service for three years to
2014
having spent more than a decade as chief
executive sheffield city council
in recent years though he himself sits
as a cross bench peer
he's advised the labour party and what
it needs to do to prepare
for government um bob kerslake what is
it
about whitehall did you get any answers
uh from dominic cummings testimony did
you learn
anything that you didn't already know
well look i've been a vocal critic of
dominic cummings and
some of the things he said but i have to
say we learnt a lot on wednesday
and we should in a sense be grateful
that we've had this
early indication of just how things
actually worked
uh behind the number 10 door and there
were
i'm afraid some serious failings that
have to be recognized
the focus has been on the political
failings but there are also lessons to
be learned
for the civil service and indeed for the
whole of the government machine
as well i'm a great supporter of much of
what the civil service does there are
some
very able people there but if we don't
learn
then there's a real risk and this is a
point that coming made
that we're simply ill-prepared for the
next time we
face this kind of crisis so yes there
are some serious lessons to be learned
here about
our preparations uh about how we
listened and learned the experiences
from other countries
about the pace of which we did things
and crucially about the openness with
which we communicated
with the public so yes definitely
there's something to learn here
visit thank you this is this is very
interesting this these issues of pace
and openness we're in a sense
illuminated by an example that he and
other people
have quoted which is that the great
success of the government during the
pandemic
whatever its other mistakes has been the
vaccine program
and that was delivered by a task force
recruited
largely from outside whitehall operating
to rules that are not unknown but quite
uncommon within white hall um
is that the way you saw it and do you
think that we don't have to go abroad
can we learn lessons from
that experience i think we can it's fine
to bring in outside people
at the right point at the right time but
of course they work with the civil
service
and crucially in this instance work with
the nhs we talk about
the success of the task force but what
about the success of our nhs
in organizing and delivering those
vaccines
a great success and we should celebrate
that i have no reverse to bringing in
people from outside
but what i think is our fundamental
challenge as a country here trevor
is our complacency in arrogance the
so-called british exceptionalism that
we're always going to be the best and we
just need to approach the lessons
learned here
with a sense of humility we have
something to learn
and something to improve and by the way
i think we should be having this inquiry
sooner rather than later i do not accept
the arguments
that we heard from the minister about
the delay uh it's
vitally important for the families who
were lost loved ones or who got long
covered
to hear those lessons now otherwise all
we're going to get is the kind of
partial
tit for tap testimonies of cummings and
others
so uh you're pretty clear really here
aren't you that
all of those people who pop up on radio
and television and say we have this
extraordinary rolls-royce
machine that actually the problem is all
to do with the politicians and their
silliness and so on
um really need to take a good look at
their
uh the way our public services work uh
bingham
made a rather interesting example where
she said that they had to call a meeting
and um they were told that they had to
invite 285
people within the civil service to it
is that the kind of thing that you think
we need to do something about
yeah we need to be more agile now don't
get me wrong there's a lot of things
that the school service does
extraordinarily well
so this is not an attack on the civil
service my argument against
coming to us that you don't change and
improve organizations by going to war
with them
but if we want to really be the best we
have to
learn lessons uh we need to be more
agile we
crucially need to be more prepared in
2019 we thought we were one of the best
prepared
countries in the world for a pandemic we
clearly weren't
similarly the communications has been a
major issue we weren't even
allowed to know who was on the sage
committee never mind what it was
actually
saying and doing i think there's nothing
short of a revolution needed in the way
we run this country it's about how
politicians conduct themselves
but it's also about how our public
servants do their role as well
not that often the head of civil service
calls for a revolution but i
i guess uh what you're saying is that if
we were hit with something similar
to january 2020 in january
2022 at the present
in the present configuration actually
we'd be no better
off uh in coping with it i would have
learned some lessons
of course i don't want to say there
won't be and indeed
there were lessons learned but just look
at the
uh way in which we handled the second
lockdown it felt like
uh we really had learned almost nothing
and this is the point kirsten has made
that you can just about understand how
things were in the first lockdown
but to go through it again in the second
lockdown shows a
a paucity of of learning really so we
wouldn't be as
better placed as we need to be if we
faced another pandemic
and crucially for me we need to be
better at two things
number one we need to be better at
long-term planning
in this country not always reacting if
you'll forgive me
to the latest news story and number two
we need to be
much much better at working across
government uh
in a collaborative way and being able to
move rapidly you don't need 250 people
in a meeting if you're going to make
serious decisions
well one quick point if i may you in a
speech when you left in 2014
uh talked about uh the need for greater
diversity of skills
and a new approach to data and evolution
patricia hodgson who you know is a
a distinguished public servant published
a report this week which actually said
that um
the civil service really needs to up its
game
in the use of technology and digital and
so on uh
do you detect that there's been any
response to your 2014 speech
uh in the seven years since in uh
improving the way we deal with um
delivery in civil service
i think we've got a lot more to do um i
believe passionately in open government
um i believe
passionately in having a more diverse
civil service not just in terms of
ethnicity and gender or those are
crucially important but actually in
terms of class as well
in terms of the range of skills and and
how much we value those technical skills
that hasn't
in the past been seen as the most
important thing to have
uh in in in being a civil servant
we now need to really recognize that
those deficiencies i talked about
have to be addressed if we're going to
be genuinely
world class we should probably in a way
stop saying the world class
until we've addressed them cursed lake
thank you very much indeed
thank you now friction between
unconventional special advisors and
senior civil servants
is not a new thing let's talk to one of
the most
talked about cuckoos in whitehall's nest
tony blair's former director of
communications
alastair campbell now
alice campbell listening to dominic
cummings i could hear the voice of a
highly intelligent charismatic
individual sitting at the heart of
government
who'd arrived in number 10 at the right
hand of the prime minister
with a mission only to find himself in
the glare of the media
unable to uh utterly frustrated by the
shortcomings of
of whitehall and the mendacity of some
of his own political colleagues
does that feel in any way like a
familiar story to you
well only up to the point where you got
to the end there because i think when we
talk about
mendacity dominic cummings is right up
there with boris johnson not least in
the brexit campaign
and i guess the equivalent i would only
compare myself
if i felt that after my time in downing
street i came out and trashed everything
that
tony blair and gordon brown stood for
and did
and i will never do that because i think
they were committed public servants who
did a lot of good for the country
and i think what dominic cummings
testimony even accepting as bob kersley
says he's a pretty unreliable witness
however what he said is borne out by
what lots of us have been saying for
some time
that this whole pandemic has been
scarred the government handling has been
scarred
by the character of the prime minister
by his inability to
to govern in a rational clear sensible
way
to appreciate systems to work with those
systems
and i thought it's interesting bob said
the point about we've got to be more
long-term
worry less about the day-to-day media i
thought one of the most telling parts of
dominic cummings
testimony was when he said and it's
something i've thought that boris
johnson is basically a journalist
and cummings said he wakes up every
morning he has a flick through the
papers
thinks what are they gonna what should
we do to sort of you know stay in the
story today
and he actually did that thing about
rubbing his fingers feeling the wind and
that is not government that is not
leadership and i think what cummings
exposed
is that if the country elects somebody
like johnson as prime minister
then the country is going to pay a very
heavy price for that we've paid it in
this pandemic
let's leave aside the question of
whether all journalists
behave in that way alastair i think i
know some who actually read
the newspapers and and so on but do you
i get your point about johnson sawn but
the truth is
it doesn't feel like the country really
agrees with you
even after cummings is uh testimony this
week opinion polls
have conservatives between 10 and 18
points
ahead and indeed in some polls they've
increased their lead post comings
well listen i honestly don't care about
the polls i care about
what i think about the country and where
the country is heading
with this prime minister and this
cabinet and you were talking there to
some of the principles of government
with lord kurzlake
well let me just go through the
principles that are meant to govern
standards in public life the nolan
principles honesty
openness which bob talked about
objectivity
selflessness integrity accountability
and leadership by example i think
johnson only scores on the last one
in that it leads by the example that
tells his cabinet ministers
they can be as useless as gavin
williamson they can break the
ministerial code as often as pretty
patel
they can lie in the way that cummings
says that the hancock has
and none of them will get held to
account for that because johnson doesn't
want to get help them held to account
because he's the worst of the lot when
it comes to dishonesty in public life so
the polls i think are a reflection of
all sorts of things their reflection
about the state of the opposition
they're a reflection of the success of
the vaccination program and people
feeling maybe maybe maybe we're just
coming out of this
this hell they're also a reflection of
the fact that i think the media
does not hold this government to account
nor does parliament frankly
does not hold this government to account
in the way that they should i think the
media has become incredibly supine in
its coverage of the government
and even on the coming stuff yes
wall-to-wall coverage
but then by the weekend it's oh well who
cares what dominic cummings thing the
sun's shining
vaccination programs going well
johnson's got married let's just move on
and i think the country's just got to
decide do we care
about the fact that we have a government
and a prime minister that was coming
and i agree with him this they are
directly responsible for tens of
thousands of deaths do we care about
that or not
do we care that a prime minister stands
up in parliament you've now got that
video from peter stevanovic
over 20 million views hardly anybody in
the mainstream media covering it
where they set out we talk about has he
broken the ministerial code it breaks
the ministerial code virtually every
time he stands up in parliament they're
meant to tell the truth
and this is what populism has done to
our politics
i we could talk about um your views uh
about uh this this government forever
and
you know and you know i you've been
pretty clear let's let's put it that way
on that but
let's just uh talk about some of the
underlying substantive questions here
some of the ones that i've talked
i was talking to bob kerslaker about
about the nature of government because
you've been
inside it one new labour minister
complained why i think while you were
still
there that he thought that when you got
into government
there was this great machine and you're
if you're a minister
you pull a lever and the machine wears
into life
and stuff happens and changes take place
and what he discovered within months was
that you pull a lever
and it wasn't connected to anything and
nothing
happened is that um sounded about right
to you
no it doesn't and also i think that's a
bit naive because if you think about how
we got into power
in 1997 was partly recognizing a lot of
the weaknesses in the system that if you
like we were up against and i think that
you know to be fair to the civil service
at the time yes there was some who were
obstructive yes there were some who were
difficult yes there were some who
weren't you know very good at the job
but a lot of them were and i think what
you've you know sorry to keep going back
to the current
government compared to a kind of what i
would call a rational government and a
sensible professional government
what happened was that when there was
clear direction from ministers
i think actually the civil service was
you know was broadly responsive
and i think one of the problems in the
pandemic has been the relentlessness of
the kind of mixed messaging
people not really knowing what they're
meant to be saying what they're meant to
be doing
johnson just making up on the hoof
whereas actually listen there were lots
of situations and tony blair famously
made that speech about the scars on his
back
about the difficulties of getting public
service reform
however we did deliver a lot of public
service reform
not least with the help of the best of
the best in the civil service but where
i go with bob
kersley by the way i do think we've got
to move away from all this language we
talk about the rolls-royce civil service
we have the best armed forces in the
world we have some of the best
but i think that we this british
exceptionalism is a is really not a
sensible way to kind of approach issues
like
the ones you're talking about let me
take it let me take you back to those
new labor years out of scandal um you
know you say you
they did terrific job in some respects
and so on they weren't always that
complimentary about you
i mean i heard a former cabinet
secretary on the radio this week
saying that some of the roth set in with
the
sofa government of the blair regime and
you were one of the people on the sofa
some of the people in whitehall would
say
this is all your fault
well i don't know who that was and and i
think that the whole thing about sofa
government
is it was just a complete nonsense tony
blair ran a very tight ship
and he embraced the civil service i
remember one of the first things he did
was took me and jonathan powell into a
room
jonathan who was the other special
adviser who was a was we were given
these
special dispensations to instruct civil
servants and he was very very clear we
work with these people we don't work
against them
and i think you'd find very very few
people who work with me
or with jonathan powell or any of the
others who were in there one of the
things i'm
most proud of actually is the people
nobody who's ever worked for me in the
civil service
has ever come out and criticized the way
that we dealt with them
and the way that we worked with them and
you know i think the other point bob
made
very quickly gone can i just tell you
another question sorry uh
but of course which is about the the
effect of the last year
there have been stories this week about
effect of on people's mental health and
i know this is something that
you are particularly uh concerned about
if you've got any thoughts about
what we ought to be think doing going
forward
well i am really worried about this
because i i understand that the
government has you know its main focus
has been
on in dealing with the pandemic but you
know the royal college of psychiatrist
has warned about mental illness being
this
the second pandemic and you know that
whether that overstates it or not i
think we all know
that there are going to be long-term
consequences from this on mental health
for students who couldn't study for
children who couldn't go to school
for business people who've lost their
business for people who've lost their
jobs
for people who've lost their loved ones
and not been able to say farewell all of
these things have psychological impact
and i do sense that with this government
from matt hancock and
and johnson and they they they just want
this is populism they want to say that
everything's fine
well actually things are not going to be
fine for some time to come and the only
way we're going to address that and get
a strategy for that
is actually if they recognize it and the
governments that are doing best in
relation to
the the health consequences the mental
health consequences of the pandemic
are those like new zealand like germany
like taiwan where they've actually said
from the word go
there are going to be mental health
consequences from this and i wish that
our government would take the same
approach
alex campbell thank you very much indeed
many of the people who suffered most
during the pandemic were frail
elderly and vulnerable around one in
three deaths from
kobe took place in care homes and we now
know that during the first wave of the
pandemic
patients taken from hospital and moved
into care homes
without being tested
mike pedro is chair of the independent
care group
uh mike padgeam can i take you back a
year and a bit
talk to us about running a care home in
those first
weeks of the pandemic trying to keep
your residents safe
but also having to cope with rivals from
hospitals
without any real way of knowing that
they weren't bringing
the virus into your care home
good morning trevor can i just extend my
condolences to all those people i've
lost loved ones and care homes um or
elsewhere in the country for that matter
because it's been a tragedy
um yes at the start a year ago it was
very very difficult we were told by the
department
uh late february actually carry on as
normal there's no reason why we think
it's going to affect you
but we could see what was happening in
europe and we as a provider actually
locked down much earlier actually on the
11th of march because we could we could
see what was coming but reassuring staff
and relatives and visitors was very very
difficult because at that time
no one knew what was actually going to
be happening it was frightening
i want to um show you i don't know if
you'll be able to see it there's a
graph of the excess deaths
uh over the last year to february
in um uh care or
people who have been in chaos people
have been in care homes and
last april the peak climbed to
6 000. i mean normally it's you know
down
uh around a quarter or third or a
fifth of that um
tell me what do you felt during
that spike i mean it must have been
mayhem
well it was i mean we we had someone who
was transferred to us from hospital
actually on the 19th of march
um at that time we thought testing was
happening in fact we found it wasn't and
we actually had to go and get the test
ourselves from the hospital
to test that person to make sure that
they weren't um
uh positive by the time we got the test
we subsequently found they were positive
and they were
re-admitted back and unfortunately
passed away yes it was dreadful we were
worried because we saw the nhs
um was dealing with a very difficult
issue they had ppe
we didn't and was reassuring our staff
and our residents that we knew what was
happening and doing the best we possibly
could it was frightening um and if it
weren't for
the hard work of social care staff and
in fact the local authorities in our
area
they would those figures i'm i'm
confident would have been much much
worse
mr cummings said this week that um
when matt hancock had put said he'd put
a shield
around care homes he was telling
untruths um somebody
is not telling the truth here uh hancock
says
he wasn't lying um who do you think
was telling the truth well i can only
give it as i see it and i don't want to
accuse
uh i weren't there to who to hear who
said what to whom all i would say is
i don't believe myself there was a ring
of protection thrown around us
in those very early days it was
difficult
we were forgotten we've been forgotten
over decades
that's the only issue in social care we
weren't prepared we weren't um ready we
didn't have the pp we didn't have the
testing
and it took the government many many
weeks to actually see what was happening
in homes
despite our best efforts and process
stations that is why providers
i think without their efforts the
figures as i said just now would be it
would have been much worse so
they take some credit particularly the
staff of course
of course there was a crisis in social
care before covid
and there is a crisis in social care now
and unless we do something about it
there will probably be a crisis
in social care in the future what do we
need to do
now well it's so so frustrating you're
right
um and i've lost faith in all
politicians really because going through
labor the coalition now conservatives
everyone's promised something and it's
never happened
i'm a loss to know what we can do in the
future all i would say if something
positive came out of this pandemic it's
got to be
the reform of social care and rather
people rather than people stepping down
now resigning i want the government to
actually give us a date when they're
going to deliver social care not move
from it if they don't deliver this time
then they need to step aside and let
someone else do it because we've run out
of patience it needs action
today mike pedram thank you very much
indeed
it for the main show don't go anywhere
though in just a moment we'll be
reviewing everything we heard in trevor
phillips
the take stay where you are i'll be back
after this short break
[Music]
you